bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 22 février
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nos invités
mais également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite on commence avec
les titres de cette édition la fin de
l'opi voie avec une dette d'environ un
milliard d'euros la structure
interdépartementale doit être rattaché à
une collectivité locale
problème la région ile de france ne
souhaite pas reprendre à sa charge le
bailleur social
l'ubs et risation une pratique qu'il
bouleverse l'économie traditionnelle et
syndicats et professionnels se sont
réunis jeudi dernier à l'assemblée
nationale à l'initiative de jean
frédéric poisson président du parti
démocrate démocrate chrétien pour en
débattre
retour sur le sujet et enfin le centre
de météo-france yvelines val d'oise
situé dans la zone d'activité de trappes
elancourt fête cette année ses 120 ans
retour sur son histoire et avant de
développer ces titres on prend tout de
suite la direction de plaisir vendredi
vers 7 heures du matin une rupture de
canalisation dans le quartier de la
boissière à proximité de l'école alain
fournier a entraîné une inondation
partielle du secteur
l'incident a entraîné des dégâts mineurs
chez les habitants mais plusieurs mètres
carrés mais recule dos se sont également
déversé sur le stade des peupliers le
terrain synthétique rénové en 2012
devront sans doute être remplacés cette
inondation a privé d'eau le quartier les
communes voisines de neauphle le château
saint germain de la grange et jeu voire
pontchartrain pendant toute la journée
du vendredi
nous reviendrons sur le sujet demain
dans notre édition du journal de mardi
avec une réaction de la mère joséphine
kozman berger et l'opievoy peut être
dissous avant la fin de l'année avec une
dette d'environ un milliard d'euros
la structure interne interdépartemental
est aujourd'hui impacté par la loi
allure qui lui impose d'être rattachée à
une collectivité locale
la semaine dernière la région
ile-de-france a annoncé officiellement
sa volonté de ne pas reprendre le
bailleur social un avenir donc plus
qu'incertain pour une structure qui
officie sur 8 départements avec
cinquante mille logements
les explications avec william el est
patrick jacques de dixmude l'opievoy
bientôt en passe de disparaître le
second
gros bailleur social de france est
aujourd'hui victime de la loi allure
l'obligeant à être rattachés à une
collectivité locale unique au 31
décembre 2016 problème valérie pécresse
présidente de la région ile de france a
annoncé le 18 février dernier qu'elle ne
reprendrait pas la structure à sa charge
le rôle de la région c'est d' impulser
une politique d'aidé par exemple les
franciliens qui le souhaitent et qui le
peuvent à devenir propriétaires
d'impulser une véritable politique du
logement en cofinançant du parc locatif
social
l'ambition la région n'est pas de
devenir de constituer un patrimoine
immobilier
autre argument avancé par la région la
dette de l'opi voix s'élevant à un
milliard d'euros
avec 58 logements étalé sur huit
départements et pas moins de dix sept
mille cinq cents logements dans les
yvelines
l'avenir incertain du bailleur social
inquiète les locataires pourquoi pas se
doter d'un outil de 80 mille locataires
c'est je comprends pas d'un côté on
favorise des regroupements
intercommunaux favorise des grosses
structures les hypers structure et une
hyper structures comme pouvait l'être
opievoy on la casse le président de l'ot
pivois pierre bédier n'ayant pas
souhaité s'exprimer sur le sujet a
annoncé lors de ses voeux que la masse
salariale ne serait pas réduite en
septembre dernier pierre bédier
également président du conseil
départemental des yvelines avait
envisagé la création d'un office
interdépartemental avec l'essonne pour
reprendre les hlm
le 8 mars prochain l'avenir du bailleur
devrait être tranchée en conseil
d'administration et des travaux de
grande ampleur à la gare de trappes ce
week-end pendant 42 heures en continu
les agents sncf sont intervenus sur deux
voies de la ligne aile afin de
renouveler deux aiguillages et plus de
100 mètres de rails
cela sans que le trafic ne
s'interrompent sur les deux autres
couloirs de circulation de la gare au
total ces trente agents qui ont été
mobilisés pour un investissement de plus
d'un million d'euros dans ses travaux de
régénération sur les 3700 km de voies
30% sont appelés être renouvelée changer
ses aiguillages permettra d'améliorer la
performance du réseau francilien le
confort des voyageurs également de
gagner en qualité chiens et l'ubs et
risation gagne de plus en plus de
secteurs le terme vient du nom
la fameuse société de transport hubert
ces pratiques ont bouleversé l'économie
traditionnelle et locations
d'appartements et les véhicules privés
par exemple inquiète syndicats et
professionnels
ils se sont réunis jeudi dernier à
l'assemblée nationale à l'initiative de
jean frédéric poisson président du parti
démocrate chrétien et député des
yvelines pour en débattre
retour sur ces enjeux avec fanny
bourdillon taxis contre vtc hôtellerie
contre airbnb l'ubs et risation de
l'économie est bel et bien en état de
marche cette révolution économique voix
des acteurs traditionnels se faire
dépasser par des start up aux
applications innovantes et soulève de
nouveaux enjeux à l'assemblée nationale
syndicats philosophe et professionnels
se sont réunis pour un colloque
parlementaire sur la fameuse hubert
isation toutes les professions sont
touchés il n'y a pas que la mienne
toutes les professions sont touchés et
je pense que il doit y avoir un débat
devant les français pour expliquer les
enjeux de la future construction de la
société française autant social
l'économique et autres l'impact est plus
large qui n'y paraît restaurant ou
encore auto écoles s'inquiètent aussi de
ce fait rue berri zay pour répondre à
ces inquiétudes le député yvelinois jean
frédéric poisson a animé trois tables
rondes où les curieux se sont mêlés aux
professionnels je vois que sa profession
est ce que j'entends ici et c'est de se
protéger
en dix ans les rênes oui il faut tout le
monde puisse respecter serré mais aussi
il y a évidemment trop de réglementation
ce qui empêche
il a quitté de se déployer dans tous les
domaines c'est vrai pour les familles
pour les collectivités territoriales
pour les entreprises pour les
associations pour les commerces pour
tout le monde et d'un autre côté
il y a un minimum de règles à adopter
sans lesquels encore une fois la
compétition n'est pas égal il faut tel
de soi donc il faut les deux assouplir
les règles et en même temps faire en
sorte que les règles une fois assoupli
s'applique pour tous l'ubs et risation
un vrai défi pour les acteurs
économiques traditionnels ces derniers
cherchent avant tout à garder le
contrôle de leurs activités
emmanuel macron devrait proposer un
projet de loi dans les semaines à venir
baptisé noé pour nouvelles opportunités
économiques
l'objectif encadrer cette économie
collaborative et accompagner les
secteurs les plus en difficulté et santé
à présent trois mois après les attentats
de paris la question du don du sang
reste d'actualité
pendant les périodes de congés comme les
vacances actuellement les réserves en
produits sanguins suisse habituellement
de fortes baisses en plus des sites de
collectes fixes
l'établissement français du don du sang
compte sur la générosité des donneurs en
organisant des collectes mobiles comme à
elancourt vendredi dernier regardez ce
reportage signé william l
en forte hausse après les tragiques
attentats du 13 novembre une baisse du
don du sang a été enregistré trois mois
plus tard elle encourt une collectes
mobiles organisées en partenariat avec
la ville et l'établissement français du
don du sang est aussi là pour rappeler
l'importance de la mobilisation des
donneurs tout au long de l'année
une occasion pour rappeler à l'ensemble
des français enfin des habitants de la
france d'ailleurs que don du sang
c'était indispensable et que ce devait
être permanent il fallait pas attendre
de circonstances aussi épouvantable pour
donner son sang ce n'était pas une
publicité mais une bonne relance pour le
fait que le don du sang était
indispensable pour pouvoir soigner un
ferme de pathologie et pas que des
blessés en plus des sites fixes ouverts
dans le département trois collectes
mobiles sont organisées chaque année à
elancourt une façon d'attirer
l'attention sur le besoin mais aussi de
permettre les dons aux habitants qui ne
peuvent se déplacer si ça peut motiver
certaines personnes qui ne font pas à le
faire
c'est très bien moi après jeu dès que
j'ai l'occasion je donne n'était sur les
a donné son sang très rapidement après
les attentats parce que baffe
c'est la seule réponse qu'on pouvait
apporter un petit peu intelligente à ce
genre de ce genre de choses puis après
il faut le faire tout le temps
régulièrement entre chaque don un délai
de trois mois est nécessaire d'où
l'importance de renouveler les donneurs
l'objectif pour 2016 52 mille poches de
sang a prélevé un défi relevé en 2015
avec 55 mille poches récoltées dans le
département et après le don du sang nous
allons parler à présente du don
d'organes pour en parler avec nous ce
soir en plateau et yolande bertrand
laborde présidente de france adot 75
bonsoir à vous merci d'être venus a sur
notre plateau alors france adore je
rappelle c'est l'association pour le don
d'organes et de tissus humains un
rapport de l' agence de la biomédecine a
été présentée donc mardi dernier il
dresse un constat les greffes sont
augmentation et les demandes aussi c'est
la plus forte augmentation d'ailleurs en
dix ans le nombre de greffes d'organes a
augmenté de 7% en 2015 par rapport à
2014 avec 5746 greffes réalisées dont
60% de greffe rénale
c'est un bilan plutôt positif vous en
féliciter ben c'est un accroissement
effectivement exceptionnelle en avait
jamais précédemment eu des taux aussi
élevé maintenant malheureusement l'écart
se creuse entre les greffes et les
personnes en attente il ya de plus en
plus de personnes qui attendent un
organe et il n'y a malheureusement pas
suffisamment greffant alors ce
classement cette information place la
france dans le peloton de tête des pays
européens avec un monde avance sur les
objectifs fixés comment ça s'explique
justement comment on vient à cette
situation c'est hâtive par rapport
justement fait il y avait beaucoup de 2
dont on soit en avant justement sur ces
dons mais qu'en même temps on monte
parfois d'honneur qui est de plus en
plus de wii alors ça ça n'a pas de
rapport c'est juste une échelle
comparative de pays à pays et l'espagne
est en tête depuis des années et puis la
belgique soutient très très bien et puis
il ya des pays où ça se passe moins bien
on va pas dénoncer parce que c'est pas
très gentil
la france avait perdu du terrain et puis
ben on est très content cette année
d'avoir reconquis une place honorable
voilà comment ça s'explique justement
c'est ça s'explique parce que il y a eu
probablement de la part du corps médical
un meilleur repérage des donneurs
potentiels des techniques un petit peu
plus haut point pour effectivement
prélevés dans une bonne condition en
ayant des hôpitaux qui sont en réseau et
qui peuvent effectivement agir en groupe
et puis effectivement il y à aussi de la
part du public
quand même petit à petit une bien
meilleure connaissance du sujet vous
faites justement des campagnes de
communication à ce propos oui alors nous
on fait tout ce qu'on peut en tant
qu'association évidemment les
associations
non pas des moyens extensible nous avons
quelques difficultés parfois mais chaque
fois qu'on nous demande effectivement
d'intervenir dans des milieux où il y a
le grand public dans les établissements
d'enseignement dans les grandes
entreprises
on y va on se déplace on explique on
tient des stands en exposant répond aux
questions on est toujours là alors dans
le rapport justement on parle et voilà
deux dossiers de plus de dons de la part
à des seniors peut-être des dons du
vivant en fait tout ce qui est donc un
moelleux peut-être fois ça c'est quelque
chose qui se développe en france alors
le don du vivant était très
marginalisées et effectivement il semble
que l'état veuille faire un effort vers
ces techniques là il semble
qu'effectivement on
stimule un petit peu plus le don du
vivant on n'y a davantage recours en
particulier en rénale maintenant le fait
qu'il y ait davantage de seniors qui
soit d'honneur c'est dû au fait que ben
la médecine progresse tous les jours on
vit de mieux en mieux de plus en plus
vieux les les donneurs comme les
receveurs avant sont âgés donc bah oui
les donneurs avant son âge mais les
receveurs aussi on l'a vu dans le
reportage précédemment par rapport au
don du sang
les attentats de paris ont mobilisé les
donneurs excuse aussi un impact je
pensais qu'il ya des gens qui sont dit
je vais prendre ma carte de donneur
d'organes est là où s'il ya des
événements comme ceux-là
là je suis très très réservé là dessus
parce que je pense que c'était tellement
affreux tellement violent tellement 50
ans les diables je pense que les gens
avaient d'autres préoccupations c'est
pas la première chose qui leur est venue
à l'esprit en se disant tiens il ya eu
un attentat je vais donner mes organes
non je ne je ne crois pas nous n'avons
pas nous noté d'inflexions
significatives dans les demandes de
carte de donneur cela dit avec le recul
plus sur le long terme
vous aurez peut-être raison cette année
donc l'année 2007 2016 pardon vous
focaliser notamment sur la loi de santé
ce que donc il ya une nouveauté à partir
du 1er janvier prochain
donc seront tous potentiellement d'un
ordre organes ce qui vous plaît nous en
dire un peu plus alors on était déjà
tous potentiellement donneurs d'organes
sanaa ça ne change pas sur ce plan c'est
simplement dans les modalités de
prélèvement et dans les modalités de
relations avec les familles avec les
proches des donneurs potentiels que les
choses risquent d'évoluer c'est à dire
qu'on revient aux fondamentaux de la loi
qui ne dit mot consent
et la loi voudrait considéré que si la
personne ne sait pas enregistrés sur le
registre du refus qui est détenu par l'
agence de là
médecine c'est que cette personne est
prélevables et donc on en sera plus un
dialogue avec la famille pour estimer
qu'elle serait l'opinion du défunt s'il
ne s'était pas exprimé mais pour
effectivement leur dire eh bien voilà
cette personne peut être donneur et nous
avons l'intention de prélever tel organe
tel organe etc et donc ils n'auront plus
le loisir d'y réfléchir et de donner un
avis ou d'estimer la vie du donneur qui
bien sûr est décédé ne peut plus
s'exprimer
alors c'est diversement ressenti les
médecins eux pensent que c'est une
atteinte à cet entourage du donneur que
c'est effectivement une violence qu'on
leur fait que c'est un traumatisme
qu'ils vont porter toute leur vie
peut-être et puis il y à une question
éthique en profondeur c'est ça n'est
plus un don
ça devient prélèvements et c'est bien
stipulé dans le corps de la loi on parle
plus d'eux dont on parle de prélèvement
et du point de vue de l'éthique
il ya une question fondamentale c'est à
qui appartient le corps est ce qu'on
n'est pas en train d'état teasé de
nationaliser un corps donc ça sera
quelque israël à partir du 1er janvier
prochain
quand si les décrets d'application dit
que les mecs ont voté une dernière
question avant de nous quitter je sais
vous recherchez des bénévoles forcément
comme toutes les associations
comment fait-on si on veut vous
rejoindre alors effectivement dans
votre grand département des yvelines
nous n'avons plus d qui la place que
l'île de france est une région où on
déménage beaucoup il ya une grande
mobilité et donc effectivement la
dernière équipe s'est délité parce que
les gens en bouger et donc effectivement
nous aimerions bien retrouver une équipe
de bénévoles qui gèrent cette
association départementale alors vous
avez sur ce petit document les infos
heures sont en déneigement bas on va de
l'écran là on souhaite rejoindre voilà
se dote que savoir à 78 at orange.fr
c'est l'adresse à laquelle vous pouvez
proposer vos services et bien évidemment
nous assurons la formation des bénévoles
merci beaucoup d'être venu son plateau
et d'avoir répondu à nos questions voilà
si vous êtes intéressé n'hésitez pas à
contacter france à 2,75 ou 78 et nous
allons parler météo à présent non pas de
la pluie et du beau temps mais du centre
de météo-france d'yveline val d'oise il
est situé dans la zone d'activité de
trappes et long cours et il fête cette
année ses 120 ans à l'origine et cie
privée
il devient structures nationales en 1913
à la mort de son fondateur
léon teisserenc de bord mélanie poker
nous en dit plus regardées
12h15 la sonde météo comme deux fois par
jour s'apprête à partir en lâchés
pratiqué depuis maintenant 120 en 1896
le plateau de trappes proche de la gare
devient un laboratoire météorologie les
hontes et sera de bord chef de la
météorologie général du bcl le bureau
central de la météorologie
on est le fondateur en 1892 leonte
seringue de bord démissionne de ses
fonctions officielles et à partir de là
il va décider de consacrer sa vie et sa
fortune à ses recherches en météorologie
dynamique en 1895 il ya le comité
météorologique internationale qui décide
de lancer une année internationale
d'observation des nuages et ses lions
des semaines de bord qui se charge lui 2
de créer assez frais de l'eau une
station française pour les mesures
d'observation de ces nuages
l'étude du temps ce set à l'époque au
sol mais léon terrain de bord comprend
que c'est d'un point de vue verticale
qu'il faut analyser
il réalise des lâchers de cerfs-volants
tracté par un treuil électrique puis des
ballons avec son laboratoire léon t sera
d'abord créé de nouveaux systèmes de
mesure des seringues de bord construit
des premiers métaireau graf c'est comme
ça ça s'appelle ces instruments qui
mesure à la fois la pression la
température et l'humidité
un petit appareil qui était comme ça qui
pesait peu près 500 grammes qu'on était
dans un petit panier equity été emporté
par un ballon qui était gonflé avec de
l'hydrogène
il ya un lâcher très vite 8 janvier 1899
qui atteint l'altitude de 12 km mais
c'est surtout ce premier ballon sonde
qui lui permet de mettre en évidence
donc là le phénomène de quasi isothermie
de poche d'air située au dessus d'une
certaine altitude et c'est ce que c'est
la découverte de ce que léon test
aiguilles même appellera plus tard la
stratosphère décédé en 1913 léon
teysseron de bord laisse un héritage
matériel mais aussi de référence l'atlas
international des nuages en 1896 et les
bases de la météorologie dynamique
rédigé tout eu avec hugo hildebrand il2
bronson météorologues suédois le
laboratoire est alors relégué à un
service d'état
il est temps à présent de parler culture
pour cela nous retrouvons à sephora
namani bonsoir sephora soeur flora alors
ce soir vous elle nous présente et
raphaël pichon chef d'orchestre et chef
de choeur de l'ensemble pygmalion
également la programmation dans lequel
east il s'inscrit pardon pour le
spectacle de versailles oui tout à fait
alors raphaël pichon d'origine
versaillaise est l'un des plus jeunes
chefs d'orchestre français il a
seulement 31 ans et c'est très rare de
réussir à devenir chef d'orchestre avant
50 ans alors effectivement il ya
quelques années d'avant c'est un surdoué
de la musique qui a déjà reçu reçu par
dont un diapason d'or en 2008 lauréat
2014 du prix pour le chant choral de la
fondation bettencourt schueller et c'est
pas fini il a même gagné une
victoire de la musique en 2015 c'est ça
on a tous dit alors il débute la musique
au sein de la maîtrise des petits
chanteurs de versailles puis poursuit au
sein du conservatoire régional de
versailles pour étudier le chant le
piano et le violent il part ensuite au
conservatoire national de paris pour
étudier la direction d'orchestre il
complète son cursus par de la
musicologie à la sorbonne
très jeune il a le rêve de créer son
propre ensemble et en 2006 ils forment
l'ensemble pygmalion avec 30 instruments
tisme et 30 instrumentistes et tout
autant de coeur cet ensemble travaille
principalement les répertoires baroque
classique et romantique avec des
instruments d'époque et depuis des
années il travaille tout
particulièrement les oeuvres de
jean-sébastien bach et jean philippe
rameau
alors cet ensemble a déjà parcouru les
plus grands opéras de france l'opéra de
bordeaux de versailles rouen à l'opéra
comique et à la philharmonie de paris et
participe également aux précise
prestigieux festival de musique à
l'étranger il a également était invitée
pour la saison 2015 2016 par laurent
brunelle directeur des spectacles du
château de versailles
oui c'est ça invités pour trois temps
forts pour cette saison alors le premier
c'était en novembre dernier pour les
funérailles de louis xiv donné à la
chapelle royale dans le cadre du
tricentenaire de la mort de louis xiv
le deuxième temps fort vient d'avoir
lieu c'était ce week-end vendredi et
samedi 19 et 20 février à l'opéra royal
pour une re création sur scène d'orfeo
l'opéra de luigi rossi comme ils
diraient et c'est le premier opéra
représentée en france c'était en 1647
c'est là la recréation sur scène du
premier opéra français qui a été donné
alors non pas à versailles puisque ce
théâtre n'existait pas à cette époque là
mais aux tuileries dans une salle
d'opéra et des deux spectacles qui a
aujourd'hui disparu
nous étions en 747 louis xiii vient de
mourir le 1014 est encore tout jeune et
mazarin décide de faire venir en france
cette nouveauté qu'est l'opéra qui vient
d'italie évidemment une oeuvre qu'on a
aujourd'hui
oublié qu'ils restaient comme un
événement très important de l'histoire
de la musique mais qu'on a un peu oublié
pour sa musique et qui pourtant est un
véritable chef-d'oeuvre d'une puissance
et d'une d'une sensibilité absolument
incroyable alors à l'époque c'était
vraiment la découverte pour le public
français du drame chanter des grands
castrats italien mais également des
premières machinerie qui permettait les
changements de décors et procurer une
illusion scénique inconnu jusqu alors
c'est très beau et prochain moment fort
pour cette saison au château de
versailles sera le 25 et le 26 mars à la
chapelle royale pour la passion selon
saint matthieu de jean sébastien bach
alors date particulièrement importante
déjà parce que la passion selon saint
matthieu c'est le sommet de l'oeuvre de
bach avec un grand dramatisme pour ce
compositeur qui n'a d'ailleurs il jamais
écrit d'opéra mais également je vous le
disais parce que bach a constitué pour
l'ensemble pygmalion un répertoire
auquel ils sont particulièrement
attachés il faut savoir qu'au début de
l'ensemble rafeli pichon formé le voeu
pour les 10 ans d'interpréter justement
la passion selon saint-matthieu donc un
moment fort en perspective c'est l'un
des plus grands chefs-d'oeuvre de jean
sébastien bach
celle aussi l'un des plus grandiloquents
en l'un des plus ambitieux aussi en
termes de taille puisque il y a deux
orchestres 2 que qui dialoguent l'un
avec l'autre et qui permettent d'avoir
une grande vivacité dans la narration de
cette histoire que tout le monde connaît
qui est celle de la passion du christ et
qui est une histoire aussi avant tout
très humaine qui exprime énormément de
sentiments très contrastées et une
musique d'une puissance absolue
ce sera donc une première pour raphaël
pichon et son ensemble nous n'avions
donc pas d'extrait à vous montrer mais
nous sommes quand même allés chercher un
extrait de l'ensemble pygmalion jouons
du bac ray que pour le plaisir
à
oh
ce sera donc le 25 et 26 mars pro ce
prochain la chapelle royale du château
de versailles merci beaucoup à sephora
c'est la fin de cette édition tout de
suite vous retrouver mickaël mille euros
pour le site sport et tous les résultats
sportifs du week-end quant à moi je vous
retrouve demain que je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée